but God what I call God and Allah are
they are they in the Muslim religion
this one and the same
I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter born sisters helped to feed those
who are in poor conditions and who don't
even have a clothing to keep theirself
warm your small donation might mean
nothing to you but it can change their
life and help them survive the winter
this year
brothers and sisters in different this
is a message to Sony fast I think that's
what his name is and his mother
um if they're watching this I hope you
both of you guys are well uh hopefully I
was going to do the video with my mom
actually but she's always in Turkey I
thought my mom and myself to you guys uh
inshallah but anyways um there was a
message there was a video that I was
watching and in that video your dear
Mother
um
she said that um is Allah and God the
same thing but God what I call God and
Allah are they are they in the Muslim
religion this one and the same Allah and
God I don't know Allah and the so
Christians and Jews believe in the same
God we just have different
interpretations of Jesus and the Holy
Spirit then Muhammad comes along but
what are we saying around 600 years
later and yeah it was 600 and he's he's
spitting all these Muhammad spitting all
these other facts spitting all these
facts but it has to be from the same God
they have to be the one and the same not
sure so I just wanted to make this
message uh to just clarify a few things
that's number one that God Almighty yes
we believe we call him Allah the one
true God
um and we believe that this God Almighty
uh that we believe in Allah
um there is not many religions we
believe there was one religion that was
sent to people from the prophet Adam to
today that was sent to different nations
different tribes to call them to the
main core message of the worship of one
God alone and that many prophets were
sent to call their Nations because their
nations would go and worship idols and
other things and that these prophets
came to call them back to the worship of
one God because if you think about it
sunny I don't know how to pronounce it
as a Sony camera Sony Yeah so basically
if you think about it and if your mom's
watching this
um my dear um I'll just refer to you as
honestly out respect I mean you're a
young woman
Yeah so basically if you think about it
just imagine for a second that you gave
birth to Sonny yeah please look at the
pronouncing her name wrong yeah you gave
birth to your son you brought him up all
the way you looked after him you cater
for him you nourished him you nurtured
him and he comes to an age where he's 18
years old and he turns around and says
to you you have done nothing for me I
don't know you I'm going to go and thank
that person or that woman across the
road or whatever it may be as a mother
how would you feel you would feel
betrayed you're foresee and gratitude in
him you'll be like why would you do that
to me I've done so much for you you'll
be so hurt as Muslims the point that the
reason why Allah sent the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is to call
people back to the uni the worship of
one God now you might be thinking how
does that relate because just imagine
that God Almighty has created us he
sustains us he's created the heavens and
the Earth everything the entire universe
the galaxies and we turn around and we
thank we go and see we're going to go
and worship Muhammad peace be upon him
oh we're going to go and worship Jesus
or Moses this is the greatest blasphemy
it's the greatest blasphemy that's why
Allah tells us in the Quran to tell the
people of the book yourself and your son
come let us come to Common terms between
us and you that we worship no other than
God so the point is Muslims we're seeing
and we love Jesus and I can remember one
video you said to your son are you going
to turn your back on Jesus I think he
would truly find Jesus when it comes to
Islam because the Jesus of Islam peace
be upon him is that he was somebody who
worshiped God Alone even if you read the
Bible what does it say hear o Israel
this is Jesus speaking to Israelites
hear o Israel your Lord God is one God
he doesn't say three in one it doesn't
say the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit he said one God so for us the
greatest blasphemy is to go and ascribe
Partners to God and give the credit of
God what he does for us and say I'm
going to worship Jesus or I'm going to
worship this Prophet I'm going to
worship the Holy Holy Spirit we say this
is a great the greatest blasphemy so in
a nutshell God Allah the true God with
his attributes we worship him and him
alone so we affirm that he is The
Sovereign he is the one who controls our
Affairs number one so we affirm his we
single him out in his lordship and
number two we're singing him out in his
worship meaning that when we pray to him
we do not go for Prophet Muhammad we do
not go through other prophets anyone we
ask him alone I was wondering today what
are some similarities what commonalities
do we have and and I'm seeing them now
so there are commonalities no 100
there's a ton of common commonalities
between the two religions I want to know
all of them I know well we're going to
keep watching you guys the people of the
book the Christians you're close to us
because Allah says in the Quran Allah
says in the Quran
um
that the people of the book are not the
same there are those who worship and
believe in God and pray at night so God
Almighty is telling us that the people
of the book are not the same yes we have
some Christians who are hostile towards
us but there are people lovely people
like yourself who are not and guess what
we can marry from you we can um even eat
from like the meat that you sort of if
it's a Christian country we have so many
similarities the only thing that Islam
says is that let's worship God alone and
single him out in his worship and affirm
his lordship and don't give the names
and attributes of God Almighty by saying
Jesus was the all-knowing or we were
just saying is he was a mighty Prophet
Mighty messenger we love him and no
muslim can be a Muslim if they don't
believe in Jesus but we do not to
increase him to a level where we say
he's God because that's blasphemy and
believe me in the Bible
It also says that on that on that day
many people will come to me and say Lord
Lord did we not prophesize in thy name
and in thy name cast out demons Jesus
will say get away from me I do not know
you why because Jesus never asked any of
his followers to claim to for him to be
seen as Divine or God Almighty he always
praised God when the man came and said
to him oh good Master what must I do he
said why do you call me good there is
only one good and that is God alone
that's what I wanted to say to your dear
Mother if she's watching this on
yourself may God guide you guys
inshallah you seem like a lovely
individuals and that's all I can say if
you have any questions I know you guys
doing a podcast with freedom for the
free Muslims uh that's gonna be amazing
I'll be looking forward to that
inshallah but it'll be really nice that
inshallah if you have any questions feel
free to contact me or the brothers are
free Muslim inshallah um that's all I
have to say and that is the message of
Islam that we worship God alone and we
obey the final prophet and the final
messenger we have the Old Testament the
New Testament and the final testament
which is upon and by the way the final
Testament is not the books that you have
today we believe we believe in Jew was
given to Jesus peace be upon him and
that's it hope you guys are well and
until next time hope you this video
clarifies and I'm not sure what we as
Muslims believe uh